thanks Rebecca giving this talk right
after lunch reminded me of the days when
I was a grad student here and we had a
brain lunches do we enter there any grad
students here who's a grad student any
grunts do you still have brain lunches
and BCS all right this is side this was
20 years ago but this is a t-shirt we
had for our brain lunch series and it
was back in the old building in e25 and
those are really good days that is 20
years ago and I was just thinking about
it today I've only been back a few times
since then but just coming back reminds
me about just what a great experience it
was here the BCS Department is fantastic
and now having it complemented with the
McGovern in the pic hour and all these
things at such a suite of great
opportunities for all you grad students
so it will just set the fundamentals for
the rest of your career as it did mine
and working in Peter Schiller's lab
which is just a fantastic experience and
for the grad students here if I have any
advice going forward coming out of MIT
it's advice that Peter gave me when I
was starting on my job search which is
be relentless and that's the only advice
he gave me an it was great advice so
what have I done since then I've been
working on vision and eye movements and
this symposium is fantastic too because
it's like my dream meeting and thanks
mayor dad for inviting me to hear all
about the coiler discharge people are
studying and the internal models that
they're using and kind of incorporating
these ideas into is just amazing and
it's a field that's really been
exploding in the last 10 years it's
really fun to be part of this I study
vision and eye movements which is a
system that we haven't really talked
about too much yet Kathy talked about it
a little bit in terms of the vestibular
system and head movements I'm just going
to talk about straight up I movements
today without moving the head and the
problem with I movements when it comes
to vision or one of the problems is that
it's very difficult to imagine how we
take the chaotic images that are
projected onto our retinas with each
quick eye movement something like this
and transform that into a stable visual
percept so we're making these jerky IM
sick
about two or three times a second and we
never really noticed we never see the
world as jumping around and this is
something we take for granted but it's a
difficult problem there have been
advances recently in computer vision to
try to figure out how to stabilize video
input for example on the fly it's very
difficult to do stabilization in real
time so this is the two images I just
showed you the raw image on the left in
a typical stabilized image on the right
this requires a lot of computational
power in order to do this in real time
people have used methods that involve
gyroscopes and accelerometers neither of
which we have in our eyes unfortunately
and other methods like computer vision
methods where you lock on to particular
salient parts of the scene and track
that or use a kind of motion flow
information but that breaks down when
you get past movements of a few degrees
and for example I can make an eye
movement from this side of the room to
this side of the room and I don't feel
like I'm falling over it's everything
seems very stable to me and there's no
stabilization and that in the technical
world that can accomplish that so why is
it so easy for us to perceive the world
as stable well the brain has an
advantage unlike holding a video camera
where you get the jitter and the
stabilization is really trying to negate
that jitter from handheld movement or
joystick movement of a security camera
for example but the brain is not only
trying to analyze that input but it's
also creating that jitter it's creating
those movements so the brain brain has
an advantage it's generating the
movements that are destabilizing the
image so just a quick review of the
visual system as you all know light
enters and the retina goes through
processing starting from v1 extra stride
areas and a couple specific outputs from
cerebral cortex that go down to the
brainstem and superior colliculus
including the frontal eye field which is
one of the main outputs of the cerebral
cortex from this superior colliculus
signals go then down to ocular motor
neurons which are akin to alpha motor
neurons that contract the muscles this
is the sensory motor pathway that we all
learn in grad school
but there's a whole other half to this
instead of a sensory motor path there is
a basically equivalent but opposite
motor to sensory paths in the brain
including in the primate brain these
motor de sensory paths come from many
subcortical areas that I won't talk
about and one of the main ones though
comes from the superior colliculus up to
the frontal eye field and it's relayed
through a part of the thalamus called
the media door media dorsal nucleus of
the thalamus now this pathway arises
from a part of the spirit colliculus
intermediate and deep layers where
saccade are represented in vector form
so every little displacement of the eye
is represented in population activity in
the colliculus and that seems to be what
sent up now when I started working on
this pathway it was known to exist this
was one of the earliest pathways
delineated with retro garrett retrograde
tracing tran synoptic tracing using
herpesvirus in frontal eye field and
looking back to synapses so we knew the
anatomy was there that was about
nineteen ninety four when that paper
came out that was at the tail end of my
grad student career so for my postdoc I
decided to try to figure out what this
anatomical pathway might be doing and
I've been studying it ever since so our
hypothesis when i started in bob Mertzes
lab as a postdoc at any i was that maybe
this is one of the long elusive pathways
for corollary discharge in the primate
brain so it's well situated to send
information about saccadic eye movements
up to this high-level visual area visual
and ocular motor area of the cerebral
cortex through the thalamus but going
into this we didn't know if it actually
did that so our hypothesis was that this
pathway may help the visual system to
account for self movements of the eyes
by providing the visual system with
predictive information about where the
eyes are going to go next and when
they're going to move and with the magic
of internal models that I don't
particularly sethi myself that can be
converted into a prediction of what the
scene will look like after the eye
movement and a comparison can be made
and if everything checks out then you
perceive the world that's stable if
there's a mismatch you don't
that's the general idea so in this
particular system to make it really
clear the superior colliculus is sending
down motor commands to premotor neurons
that actually move the eyes and our idea
is that it sends a copy of these motor
commands back up to the cerebral cortex
and the frontal eye field seems to have
a rather privileged access to this
information this pathway from the
intermediate layers of the colliculus
does not reach pryda lobe for example
now we don't know if this is actual
branch of the descending efore an output
as opposed talked about earlier this
morning it probably isn't they may be
separate neurons projecting in both
directions that's unknown at this point
so to study this pathway we used a
variety of classic methods in awake
behaving monkeys we would record from
single neurons and we record at all
three levels of this pathway at the
source at the relay and at the target
but every neuron that we recorded from
was identified as being part of the
pathway by combining the recordings with
electrical stimulation methods in with
the electrical student so we would have
the stimulating electrodes implanted
with their tips in the intermediate
layers of the colliculus or in the
frontal eye field and those are semi
chronically implanted for a couple
months and on a daily basis for example
we would record from media dorsal
thalamus and try to find the relay
neurons you've seen a little bit about
these methods this morning and using an
atomic activation also worth the drama
course adaptive activation so whenever
we encountered a neuron and thalamus we
would try to drive it synaptically from
the colliculus and at this also then
we'd switch over and try to drive it
antidromic ly from the frontal eye field
and if it was double identified in this
way then we knew it was a real a neuron
in the pathway and not just a generic
salamis neuron and we use similar
methods to look at the source neurons
going up in the target neurons so when
we identified such a neuron we would run
the wake behaving monkey on a whole
battery of tasks i'll just talk about
one the memory delayed scod task which
you're probably familiar with monkey
fixated a spot in the screen like right
there and then another spot I don't have
to laser pointers but imagine that
staying there
another spot flashed in the periphery
and the receptive field and then the
flash and then after a while after about
a thousand milliseconds randomized
fixation spot disappeared in the monkey
makes a saccade in total darkness to the
remembered location so you can look at
neuronal activities aligned to many
different events in a task like this
I'll just talk about the activity that's
aligned with making the Sekot itself if
this pathway from colliculus to frontal
eye field is a corollary discharge
pathway then it should send predictive
information up to the frontal eye field
in other words it shouldn't jude send
neural activity that's not just
responding to making a saccade but is in
advance of the secod and should describe
the type of saccade that's going to be
made the vector of the cicadas well it
should send both what where and when
information and so recording from the
relay neurons in media dorsal thalamus
that is exactly what we found so this
shows example activity from one double
identified real later on a line to the
target on set the delay activity during
the memory period and this is a cue to
move and then this is aligned with the
saccade initiation so the activity is
pretty quiet until about 80 milliseconds
before the squad starts and before the
eye even budges the activity starts
accelerating and it peaks right at the
time of the Scud in each tick here is
about 100 milliseconds this is another
neuron just to show that while most of
the neurons had this predictive activity
with respect to the movement some also
had visual activity and other types of
activity earlier and this is typical of
what you would find in the source
structure the intermediate layers of the
colliculus so the real later on seemed
to be sending the information pretty
faithfully up to the frontal eye field
so the timings right and we also looked
at the spatial aspects of the movements
and the neurons also coded for specific
vectors of movements so these neurons
head movement fields in other words they
would fire for certain ranges of vectors
of cicadas starting from the center but
not for other ranges so very specific
information about when the squad would
art and where it would go and this is
true for about three quarters of all the
neurons that we studied in the and the
pathway in the thalamus also true for
the source neurons in the recipient
neurons which I'm not showing here so
the first major result just going in
studying this well-defined anatomical
pathway and seeing what is the
information actually carried in this
pathway was that there's a strong
component of movement movement related
activity being sent up to the frontal
eye field it looks a lot like what you
would expect to be going down toward the
muscles but it's going the wrong way
it's going up instead so therefore this
pathway first of all sends predictive
information about cicadas to the frontal
eye field then we asked well does this
information actually represent any
saccade that could be made each superior
colliculus so there's two of them of
course on either side of the brain stem
each one represents only half of the
visual field and only half of the
movements that could be made the
movements made into the contralateral
space from that click euless so
everything I've talked about so far is
all homo lateral pathways so from for
example the left colliculus to the left
frontal eye field but we also asked is
there any crossover we knew that there's
some anatomically there appeared to be
some evidence for cross over from the
other click euless to a frontal eye
field so for example from the right
colliculus to the left frontal eye field
so we also asked if if that was a
functional pathway and if it were then
that would indicate that a single
frontal eye field is receiving
information about cicadas mating made in
any direction which is very useful for
internal models that are trying to use
the information for updating visual
representations so to do this study we
recorded from the frontal eye field so
now we're recording from the target zone
of these pathways and we put stimulating
electrodes in both colliculi and we
would alternately stimulate one
colliculus or the other colliculus and
see if we could worth the drama klee
drive the neurons that we recorded from
in a single frontal eye field so I'm
just going to show you the response
fields of neurons in the left frontal
eye field
of subjects that we did this experiment
on so if if you're recording from the
left frontal eye field and you can
synaptically drive and the neuron from
the left colliculus so the left click of
this left frontal eye field everything's
aligned everything should be
representing contralateral space and
that's what we found this is this the
average receptive field / 27 neurons
that we could drive in this way and this
is just act the general activity of the
neurons the visual and motor responses
compared to the baseline firing rate of
those neurons with respect to space so
these neurons are very nicely tuned for
contralateral space highly significantly
just like you would expect and this is
typically what you'd find for just if
you're just in the frontal eye field
randomly recording neurons without
looking at their connections so
everything's contralaterally tuned if
it's driven from the same side click
euless we would find occasionally some
neurons that were driven only from the
other colliculus from the contralateral
colliculus the right colliculus is
representing left visual space and
leftward movements which is the wrong
side for the frontal eye field that
we're recording from nevertheless in
neurons that could be just sitting right
next to the other neurons when we
identify them as receiving input from
the other side of the brain stem
colliculus they were actually tuned for
hipster lateral space the wrong
direction so this supported the
hypothesis that the colliculus
information is lateralized first of all
but that both colliculi send information
up to the single half of the cerebral
cortex where it could be at least in
principle combined to give a full field
representation of all I movements and
just to show that this isn't like post
akattak activity or something strange
this shows the activity patterns of
spike density functions of all the
neurons that were yipsalot early tuned
and contralaterally tuned in the frontal
eye field and the ipsilateral e2 neurons
were pre psychotic just like the
contralateral e2 neurons they all look
the same it typically had a really nice
visual response and they ramped up their
activity just before the saccade and
at the time of the secod so therefore
this pathway send the squirrel or
discharge or predictive information
about Scott's to the frontal eye field
and integrates this information
bilaterally at a single frontal eye
field so this is all well and good and
this is correlational information it
shows that activity is in the pathway
and that the activity is appropriate for
being a corollary discharge signal but
it hasn't proved anything in terms of
does this pathway or does this these
signals do anything so the next step was
to perform causal experiments where we
perturb the pathway or manipulated it to
see if the results would be as predicted
from a corollary discharge function so
does this predictive information affect
visual processing in the frontal eye
field because our overall hypothesis is
that this is advanced information that's
used by the visual system for updating
the visuals seen across the Cod's and
stabilizing the scene so it better at
least effect visual neurons in the
frontal eye field in some way so to test
that hypothesis we inactivated the
pathway at the relay site so after
mapping out the media dorsal thalamus
relay neurons in a monkey we would go in
and target Moosa mall injections Moo
small as a GABA agonist inhibits neurons
for it takes about 20 minutes on set and
then lasts for about four or five hours
so we would inactivate the relay zone
before we did the inactivation we would
isolate a neuron in the frontal eye
field we would map out its visual
properties we would inactivate the
thalamus wait for the most bollin to
take effect and keep recording from that
neuron for as long as we could to
compare the visual responses afterwards
to before the inactivation now there are
a lot of different visual properties of
neurons the one that we were interested
in that could be linked to a internal
model idea is a property called pre
psychotic remapping or shifting visual
receptive fields so you all know that
many neurons of the brain have visual
receptive fields of course and so for a
typical neuron if a monkey is fixating
here the monkey sees the whole scene it
perceives the whole scene but any
individual neuron typically only sees a
part of the scene that's the receptive
field of the neurons for example the
boat and for most neurons in the visual
system probably the receptive fields
just simply move with the eyes just like
retinal receptive fields would when the
eye moves the receptive field just comes
along for the ride it's a very passive
receptive field but for other neurons in
the visual system the receptive fields
are more active they move actually
before the eyes move and this was
discovered by genre nadeau ml Carroll
Colby and Mickey Goldberg in 1992 so for
these neurons you might have a monkey
fixating here and recording from a
neuron with a receptive field over the
boat but just before the eye moves in a
certain direction there seems to be a
predictive signal arriving at that
neuron because the neuron will shift its
receptive field in line with the
upcoming eye movement and the I hasn't
even moved yet but the neuron becomes
sensitive to stimuli in a new part of
space that we call the future field
sometimes it completely loses its
sensitivity at the receptive field
sometimes it maintains in both places
but the important thing is that it moves
its visual sensitivity before the eye
moves then the eye moves and catches up
to it and the future field becomes the
classical receptive field again so we
know that such neurons have to be
receiving corollary discharge because
they shift their receptive fields in
specific directions depending on the eye
movement that's about to occur and they
shift those receptive fields before the
I women actually occurs so our
hypothesis is that this pathway through
media dorsal thalamus is what's
providing that corollary discharge
information so our prediction would be
then that in the intact animal before we
inject the Moose Amal a monkey would be
fixating here and the neuron may have a
receptive field let's say up into the
right like this and then corollary
discharge or a predictive signal about
the saccade arrives and that's used to
shift the receptive field to a new
location
and the neuron now becomes sensitive to
this location the future field so if the
pathway is providing that predictive
signal then silencing the pathway should
silence the predictive signal and remove
the shift so the neurons should still
have their classical receptive field but
they should be unable to change their
sensitivity just before the saccade in
order to test this we used a classic
shifting receptive field task that was
published first I think by Nakamura and
Colby in 2002 it's very simple task
monkey just fixates a spot shown here
for a while and then the spot disappears
new spot appears in the position where
that we want this akattak vector to go
and then after reaction time the monkey
makes the secod to the new location they
do that over and over again and on each
individual trial we flash visual probes
at different places and times to test
the sensitivity of the neuron so we may
flash a little visual probe that's task
irrelevant a little white probe the
monkey is not allowed to look at it
either early in the fixation when there
shouldn't be a shift should just be a
classical receptive field or late in the
fixation just before the I moment when
you should expect to see maximum shift
and we flash it either at the classic
receptive field or at the future field
we also flash these probes that many
other times and locations that I'm not
going to talk about here in between near
the Scott octagonal ANC's and so forth
and that's all published in previous
work and I'm just going to talk about
these four conditions so this shows
typical activity of a neuron in the
frontal eye field that we recorded from
during an inactivation the icons up here
just remind you of what the task is
basically just making a squad down to
the right I'm washing probes at
different times and places if we flash
the probe long before this Cod during
early fixation if we flashed it at the
receptive field the neuron had a
vigorous visual response that's
receptive field of the neuron if we
flashed it in the future field location
by definition there
had no activity because this is outside
of the classical receptive field of the
neuron and it's a long time until the
eye movement is going to occur if you
flash the probe just before this Cod and
to do this you actually flash it at
random times after the cue to move
because the reaction time with the
reaction time variability to never know
exactly when the Scott is going to
happen but on average four probes
flashed about 70 milliseconds before the
scott and and they disappear before the
cicadas made so there's no smearing of
the visual information on the retina or
anything like that this particular
neuron still had a response at the
receptive field but now it was
vigorously responsive for probes flash
in the future field as well whereas
before it wasn't so this is a typical
shift that you would see in the frontal
eye field again some of the neurons also
would completely have their receptive
field activity eliminated but for
two-thirds of the neurons I would say it
you get this bimodal effect now when you
were so we record from a neuron we
documented shifting receptive field then
we inactivate the pathway and remember
our prediction is that this activity
should go away but this activity should
stay so when we retested this neuron
after in activating the pathway first of
all receptive field activity was still
fine the neuron didn't just go blind or
anything but the future field shift went
way down it was never completely
eliminated but in this particular case
for example it went down by almost
eighty percent of its original activity
this was true in the overall population
that we studied during the inactivation
receptive field activity didn't go down
significantly but future field activity
went down by about half whether you look
at whether you just average all the raw
firing rates of the neurons or if you
normalize them just to look at the
percent of deficit for each individual
neuron regardless of its firing rates
strength so on average there's about a
50 percent deficit when you inactivate
this pathway so there seemed to be other
pathways probably
that are contributing as well but this
pathway seems to be if not the majority
at least half of the coiler discharge
that these neurons are receiving so we
also know that this pathway does
something influences visual processing
in the frontal eye field the specific
kind of visual processing of the recycle
acree mapping or the shift so finally
we've started to ask well how exactly
does this happen at the level of the
cerebral cortex when the corollary
discharge arrives in the frontal eye
field it's somehow combined with visual
information that's arriving from extra
strike cortex both of these inputs
arrive at layer four in the frontal eye
field layer for a frontal eye field has
a pretty good layer for a pretty good
granule layer it tapers off as you go
down into the sulcus but in general has
a really nice layer for layer for
neurons can be excitatory they can be
inhibitory there's a whole mixture and
the question we asked next was if you
just look at those layer for neurons
that are receiving the visual and the
corollary discharge information can you
tell something about how the information
is combined if you compare the signals
of the neurons with their beautiful
putative morphologies whether their
putative ly inhibitory neurons or
excitatory neurons or things like that
we unlike in slice experiments and a lot
of preparations we can't actually see
the neurons that we're recording from so
we have to use other techniques to infer
what types of neurons they are so first
of all we identified neurons in layer
for the frontal eye field using again
orthodontic activation from the
colliculus the meteoroid so thalamus
projects primarily to layer four and a
little bit of deep layer three so when
we would identify neurons in the frontal
eye field that could be orthodontic ly
activated from the colliculus we would
then test the monkey on the shifting
receptive field task and ask whether
these very first neurons in the circuit
shifted their receptive field or not and
again these neurons have unknown unknown
morphology a priori they could be either
excitatory or inhibitory
both types are in layer 4 to try to
infer the morphology we would compare
the recorded neurons the layer for
neurons with neurons in the same
structure the same frontal eye field
with a known morphology the neurons that
we could anatomically to activate from
the colliculus these are all layer 5
pyramidal neurons the only neurons up in
frontal I feel that project down to
click this are large pyramidal neurons
in layer 5 so to do this analysis we
would look at the action potential
waveform I think most of you are
familiar with this idea for individual
neuron you look at the waveform and you
basically measure its width every paper
on the subject measures width in a
different way and so we used all of them
and we combined the width measurements
in into aggregate index so we call an
inhibitory index this just shows two
example waveforms of a putative
inhibitory neuron versus a wider
actually this is a known pyramidal
neuron using a single width to cut to
the chase of all the neurons we recorded
from in layer 4 they segregated pretty
well according to this inhibitory index
where zero would be no evidence that the
neurons in inhibitory neuron and and one
would be strong evidence that the neuron
is an inhibitory interneuron again
compared to this calibration set of
known pyramidal neurons so we just
segregated this into putative excitatory
neurons 11 of them putative inhibitory
neurons with narrow narrower waveforms
and actually higher spontaneous firing
rates too and then there were some in
the middle that were not classifiable in
this way we call these ambiguous neurons
and we don't know what they are and then
we tested as we recorded from these
neurons monkey did the shifting
receptive field task what we discovered
was that each type of neuron in layer 4
actually conveys a component of the
shift doesn't compete convey the full
shift that you would see in layer 5 for
example the putative excitatory neurons
they changed their visual response just
before a saccade was made but they
changed it at the receptive field only
they didn't have any future field
response but their change at the
receptive field was an increase in
activity at the receptive field just
before the eye movement the ambiguous
neurons were the really interesting ones
unfortunately that there are also the
scarcest ones but they were the only
ones and all of them did this they
changed their visual response at the
front at the future field they were the
only ones that showed a shift putative
inhibitory neurons we were excited about
probably parvalbumin positive classic
fast spiking neurons they didn't do
anything so they had a beautiful they
all had receptive fields but they
neither changed the receptive field for
the movement at the receptive field
location or at the future field location
just retinal type locked receptive
fields in contrast we also recorded from
layer 5 neurons as i mentioned to use as
a calibration set for doing this sorting
and we also ran these neurons on the
shifting receptive field task and as the
population level and for most of the
individual neurons they showed the whole
shift in other words they have the
classic profile of decreasing their
activity at the receptive field and at
the same time increasing their activity
at the future field so both all the
components combined and we publish this
a couple years ago so what we think kind
of the simple way to look at this is
that you have all the you have the
pieces of this process at the input
layer layer for where the visual
information the quarterly discharges
initially combined and at the micro
circuit level or maybe at a larger
network level this is then progresses
into the full process of the entire
pre-socratic remapping phenomenon so in
conclusion we've been elucidating a
neuronal pathway for seeing while moving
stabilizing the visual input from moving
sensors is a hard problem and a
technical level people are getting close
to being able to do this but the brain
does this flawlessly the brain solution
is to
use at least in part this pathway from a
brainstem saccade related area the
spirit click euless that ascends to the
frontal eye field which is at the apex
one of the apex is of apices of visual
processing in the cerebral cortex so
what we've shown is that this pathway
conveys psychotic signals so it's not
sending weird signals like just visual
signals or silence it actually is
conveying psychotic signals of the right
timing and directional selectivity to
the frontal eye field it conveys from
both sides of the motor brainstem in
order to provide full field coverage of
the work space for the eye movements it
does influence visual operations in the
target area and it's probably doing this
via local micro circuits in layer for
progressing to layer 5 probably through
layer 23 of course which we haven't
studied so just some implications for
the in the context of this symposium
we're all familiar with the idea again
of sensorimotor transformations and we
know that in the primate brain there are
many different visual motor levels from
the retina through extra strike cortex
to the output nodes of the cerebral
cortex including frontal eye field where
say signals are sent down to the
brainstem both the colliculus and also
the ponds which I didn't talk about
today from the colliculus signals are
sent to the pontine circuitry that does
all the timing of the muscle
contractions and finally it's all
combined at the motor neurons that
innervate the muscles so it's classic
visual motor transformation anatomically
we know that each of these kind of
coarsely defined levels projects
backwards but only projects to the
immediately preceding level so motor
neurons have collaterals that go back
but they only go back as far as the
pontine circuitry that does the timing
of the saccade they don't reach the
spear click this as far as we know the
pontine circuitry however the ponds and
the reticular formation they do send
feedback to the spirit colliculus
putting superior colliculus in the loop
and of the psychotic generating circuits
but as far as we know they don't project
up to the cerebral cortex
there hasn't been any well-defined
anatomical evidence for that yet to my
knowledge the superior colliculus on the
other hand the intermediate layers do
project through this thalamic mediated
pathway to the frontal eye field and the
frontal eye field of course has a lot of
reciprocal projections to the areas that
supply it with visual information such
as to the parietal lobe and li p so
there is definitely corollary discharge
flowing in this overall system but it's
not going all the way from the motor
neurons to the visual system what we see
from the anatomy and from studying this
one link of the chain physiologically is
that there seems to be a progression of
corollary discharge signals from stage
to stage each probably speaking its own
language so all the motor neurons know
about is muscle contractions they
innervate certain muscles and they
contract them for a certain amount of
time really they can't even talk to the
superior colliculus which is all about
space and vectors of movement but they
can talk to the pontine circuitry and
they seem to do so with their
collaterals the pons is all about timing
and they can send information back to
the colliculus which has some dynamics
information the cliq of this is a big
spatial map of the workspace and so as
the frontal eye field so these two can
talk to each other in the spatial code
and the frontal eye field in cerebral
cortex is a little more abstract kind of
at the more cognitive level of planning
and they probably frontal eye field is
probably receiving this information we
don't know what these feedback
projections do but they may be involved
in that more planning related aspects of
attention motor preparation things like
that all of this I would consider to be
core Larry discharge but perhaps in a
different way than is classically
thought so corollary discharge we know
and we've heard about a lot today it's
essential for internal models of
perception in action but what is it
exactly it's certainly not a signal sent
from alpha motor neurons to sensory
areas and we've seen that again and
again even in in vertebrates there's
very little evidence for such a direct
connection in the primate brain it seems
to be a series of signals
through a chain of circuits so just I
want to leave you with this while it's
useful to discuss internal models for
vision in broad terms like one block
diagram representing all the vision in
the movements and how it feeds back
these serial corollary discharged
signals suggest that there may actually
be multi stage models that saw each
solved distinct problems in their own
language whether its muscles are timing
your space and since I'm not a model or
I pose that as a challenge to the
modelers out there to try to incorporate
this into their ideas thank